what if though it was about her what if
it was like am I the [__] so I've
been poisoning my girlfriend it might be
you know like it could be like yeah am I
the assle and she's not getting sick
what the [__] am I the [__] for
poisoning
[Music]
her all right this is um this is going
to make you think twice about stuff that
happens at comedy shows oh okay what's
up tell me what's up [__] in the
green room cuz let me tell you I ain't
stopping nothing someone get into a
fight no no no so this is actually a
really really amazing story it's uh
basically there's these two girls that
are at a comedy show together I like it
already one of them um gets up to uh
kind of just move through the AIS and
she accidentally like bumps this dude or
or something and gets a drink spilled on
him right so then he starts cussing the
girl out should calling her a fat [__]
and stuff
oh drink minimum W wi you know bag did
her did her belly hit the drink well
she's not even fat she's not she's all
like I mean not she's just not fat why
you move your fat ass my fat joke was
always like slim B Slim Fast [__] Slim
Fast [__] slim like girth control have
you had a slim fast though it's actually
kind of tasty right let's talk about SL
sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry what's the
best flavor what's the best one no it
tastes like [__] it tastes like
chocolate milk best flavor dude go ahead
go ahead so the actual story isn't
literally that one of them's fat
basically um the girl she goes to like
help her friend that's getting cussed
out the guy starts cussing her out so
they get in this like you know little
bit of a scuffle a little bit of fight
but then you think it would end there
yeah for 15 years 15 years she goes on a
Revenge tirade on this guy's life what
that goes to which one the fat the fat
one there's no fat girls oh no but the
one the one he called fat the one he
called fat or the or the friend the
friend the friend you're the friend
basically put yourself in the in the
shoes of the girl that's like seeing her
friend get cussed out yeah yeah yeah
this is the girl that's like amazing so
what happens is she ends up figuring out
who this guy is ooh this sounds good and
then the first thing she does so this is
a long time ago the um she this is back
when this is before internet well I
don't know if it's before internet K but
it's before it's before Breaking Bad was
like all the episodes are Rob so she
finds this guy's Facebook and she sees
that he likes watching certain shows
that's so funny and she makes these
accounts and just sends him spoilers
over and over and over because like she
looks up the upcoming spoilers of every
episode and she starts sending them to
him and he starts making statuses like
who the [__] keeps sending me these
things ruining all my shows and uh
that's [__] hilarious long con yeah
Walking Dead and Breaking Bad she starts
[__] with him all sh like who has the
time to do all that yeah bro get a job
lady yeah hey you know what the next day
move on and live your life like [__]
you could have put that energy in your
life and you would own a [__]
business oh but that sounds so fun
though what she's doing this is
recreational time JIS yeah mean like
when you're up in heaven and the God's
going through your [__] review is
like [__] you wasted 85% of your time
uh ruining this guy's life like it was
worth it was so worth it though it was
wor you call my friend Fat ah hey call
my friend Fat like yeah that's
ridiculous for 15 years he just like
keeps [__] with them here and there
and then it culminates at a point where
she ends up uh So within this 15 years
she ends up going to the same freaking
College as this same guy who and does he
even know no he doesn't know what he he
has no idea so then was he so drunk that
night he doesn't even know yeah it says
he was so drunk that night he didn't
never knew that's good that's good oh
that's what it say there's a a point
where basically she ends up in the same
class as the dude oh stalker but she
knows him he doesn't know her yeah she
she's they know this dude he has no idea
that these people hate him this they've
bro this is you yeah yeah yeah this is
the show you roles revers yeah this is
to show you he ends up in her basement
acts dumb like oh it in he's like I know
this [__] so one day he's doing
a last presentation and uh I guess like
he's there's a projection screen and
it's showing what what's on his laptop
and she sees in a tab a user name of
something and she's like oh now I can
like find other things that he doesn't
oh wow this [__] is crazy wild don't
[__]
with She searches his username and finds
that he has a Reddit account and then
goes on Reddit and sees what he's been
posting oh no and here's the crazy is it
good stuff what kind of stuff is it well
here's here the craziest thing is this
chick's named Ryan aay
no I I use my powers for good so um she
she finds like his Reddit the crazy
thing is that she doesn't even want to
say what she found but she said it was
so bad that child pornog she sent it to
his this guy's
fiance and broke them up but he had a
come in she was going to find out
eventually that's [__] crazy bro
doing God's work though oh my God that's
crazy she might have say that so what
was it we have no idea what it was no
she wouldn't want she didn't want to say
it it's a [__] Shir but she said it
was she said it was bad enough that you
if this was your partner you would want
to know so she sent it to she sent it to
his uh fiance and then she broke off the
engagement wow and then married someone
else has kids what if though it was
about her what if it was like am I the
[__] so I've been poisoning my
girlfriend it might be you know like it
could be like yeah am I the [__] and
she's not getting sick what the [__] am
I the [__] for poisoning her yeah
like what if it's some [__] like that
and she goes oh this is [__] be this
guy's a scumbag I'm poisoning my
girlfriend as the opening
line how to poison my
girlfriend that's
funny but yeah it's it's um that that
from the second that happened at the
comedy show 15 years till now like
that's the craziest thing man she never
let it go he must have been real nasty
for her to be like you know what I'm
going to get this [__] I'm
scared of people that are that petty
yeah but well now but now you can with
technology now you can you can be Petty
but also don't be a dick like it's it's
his if like if he said that to guys a
guy we will'll just throw down right and
then we'll get it over with but then
it's like what's a girl going to do she
why you cursing a lady wait wait so you
think it's a girls uh the guy's fault
for being a dick well he I mean he
overreacted in in the story at least we
don't know his side cuz we don't even
[__] you know but based off of what
he apparently does on Reddit he wasn't a
dick once right right right so you think
it's just Karma of like him just [__]
with the here here tell me if this is
tell me this bad if this is bad here's
what he did he stood up he called her a
fat [__] so he's funny the girl said
sorry even after that and he wasn't
hearing the apology and spit on her oh
dude on somebody you should get your NE
slash I think you're going get buuck
dude so that girl goes to the bathroom
to clean herself up from The Spill and
then the main girl goes up to the man to
confront him and uh she's screaming in
his face telling him that's assault
you're disgusting you're trash and then
um and then he calls her an ugly [__]
oh okay so he's still funny this
douchebag deserves a lot of [__] you
can't spin on nobody bro I been this
okay so I been this [__] douchebag
all right oh really and let me tell you
that's why I'm like kind of like on his
side but then I'm like think like well
cuz you have empathy for him this is
what happened to me that I'm like okay I
deserve everything this car [__]
pulls in right like without letting me
know he's going to go in my Lane yeah
and I'm driving I'm in high school by
the way and like and I'm listen to
[__] 50 cents so my heart is pumping
and this guy's [__] merges without
putting his light or the whatever it is
he just goes into my L I almost hit him
so I'm like I press the brakes and I and
I'm like what the [__] you [__] idiot
yelling all this [__] B B B I'm on his
ass like [__] honking and I see like
his little like U side Mir side mirror
and I can see is like a [__] dwee
dude I like the [__] [__] this guy so I
was just like the fact that he didn't
pay attention you stupid [__] I'm my
gangster [__] whatever then I [__] go
around and this guy just starts [__]
following me oh no and I'm like great I
realized they're like oh this
[__] is following me like all
right that's what's up so then I see
there's a guy in the passenger seat too
like so I'm thinking like [__] I'll [__]
both of y'all up in my head I'm really
thinking so I pulled into like a
neighborhood and yeah he gets out the
car his dad comes out he's teaching his
son how to drive and I'm the one that's
being the aggressor so then he's letting
me know like hey mother he's like hey
what the [__] is your problem like
that's my son like trying to drive and
you're like you know you're you're
you're he's freaking out he's crying and
[__] like cuz you're doing this like
this not and I'm just kind like oh my
bad no you should have [__] both of
them no he wants to [__] me up he's like
no no get out the car if you want to
[__] it and he's a real
yeah like I seen like I feel like he
just got out like this guy is a [__]
real did he have socks to his knees yeah
he's one of those guys yeah he had a
[__] belly you know what I mean and
he had a [__] muscle shirt and he I
knew he was a real one cuz he said get
out the car homie and that's when I'm
like all right sorry I'm
sorry dude I went from 50 Cent to
Beyonce so quick on my radio I went you
know what there's nothing th about me
after getting punked you can't listen to
50 Cent album been there this was all my
single ladies all
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it went from
that to Shakira Shakir I'm like all
right I'm switching [__] genres right
now dud sh yeah dude and uh so I
understood I was in the wrong I got a
little too a honk would have been okay
but I took it too far when I'm honking
and I'm on his ass and I just took it
too far hey this is how we learn our
lessons though right like we got to get
checked get checked got checked even as
children it's like it might be common
sense that something's dangerous but
it's only Common Sense after you learned
it the hard way you know what I mean so
like you got checked and that's the
point where this dude he's obviously
still [__] around somehow doing
something wrong you know what I mean so
so it's hard to empathize how long are
you going to keep getting checked for
like years hey but would you if you if
someone spit on you bro that's pretty
crazy you spit on your friend too spit
on a spitting on a lady a random lady
that's pretty crazy I don't know you did
anything wrong spit is wild spit is wild
spitting is it elevates the situation
from calling someone a fat [__]
spitting goes up here I think spitting
on a dude is already crazy but spitting
on a lady spits on me bro I might
[__] try to kill him dog swear to God
I might try really someone spit on me
that's that's next that's bow Warfare
LEL that's B Warfare it is but spit is a
it's and if it lands too oh if it hits
oh bro I think I might swing first it's
a crazy I think I might just swing but
think about what kind of a [__] you
have to be to get mad because someone
spilled your drink like if someone
spilled my drink I'll be like whoopsie
oh [__] okay that's it it doesn't
[__] bother me but then the fact that
he got his he's in the bunch and he's
being aggressive toward women like that
to me publicly too yeah that's a weird
[__] yeah he's definitely weird
at Monster Jam I had a whole like
[__] super sized Coke and I spilled
it on the old man's leg next to me the
whole [__] Cup oh my God and then uh
I I felt so [__] bad I started I just
dri it for him I was just like I'm so
sorry sir I was like what else can I do
and then I um I gave him all like I had
like an extra sweater and I just like
let him sit on it and Sh I did
everything I could and then at the end
he was like at the end he was like hey I
hope you have a nice day no one's ever
done that much for like to remedy like a
dude you just totally checked me off
dude appreciate that one time this uh
lady spill I was sleeping on a flight
and this lady spilled hot coffee on me
and I I got and I was like I woke up
like
that dude it was [__] up it was hella
[__] up you were sleeping you had like
a pompe nightmare dude it was on Vivo
aerobus bro we're flying back from guara
and it was like 4 it was like 6:00 a.m.
we were up all night and I finally fell
asleep she spilled hot coffee and I was
like dude I freak the [__] out woken up
with h my belly was all redo I got burns
on my and what did she do for
reparations she just said sorry a bunch
of Spanish yeah but then you don't call
her a fat [__] and want to [__] her up
yeah like I just was like all right I
was really mad about I was like damn
this is a really funny story second now
I'm just up and I was fine if it's an
honest mistake you can't really get mad
but I Spit on her I [__] spit on her
yeah yeah I got a guy that that put a
snot on my shoe like and now we were
playing basketball snot rocket and then
he just [__] went like just playing
and then and then just bam yeah accident
but talking about accident so but it was
like he should was on my shoe yeah hey
bro did he clean it off of you no no
that's the thing that's that's [__] up
oh [__] my bad dog and he just kept
moving and I'm like no yeah there your
bad and I'm like it's there on my Sho
how am I going to get it off you know
what mean yeah he needs to clean it off
he should have licked it off
the he should have just snorted
imagine he gets a lace it goes
oh